DAZHI PENG: Hi! Guys glad to see you back from Spring Break.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah. I just came back from North Carolina yesterday. I got depressed again, coming back to Facebook.
Yooni Choi: Hi me, too. I'm a staying in the polls of Cancun.
DAZHI PENG: Good. Let's start our weekly stand up meetings. We have a mentor meeting coming up next week, and I think it'll be great for us to space up our world today and make progress before meeting with them next week.
Jeffrey Feng: Yes, so far, I think UN has done a great job on investigating different call services as our efficiency.
Jeffrey Feng: But the action items and the general items are still on create us.
Yooni Choi: I agree there are many Nlp services that we can explore to achieve this task. Have you guys heard about the chat gpt from open AI? I think it would be a great Canada for this task.
DAZHI PENG: Yeah, it's amazing. I've been using it extensively for all my Icc project. I know nothing about spark people and educating a lot of great examples of collaboration.
DAZHI PENG: I think we could use it to extract an agenda and action items from the meeting Transcript.
Jeffrey Feng: Oh, then, would you be able to take on that task by next week? I believe Chat Jbt: would definitely help us allowing this project.
DAZHI PENG: Yeah, sure thing.
Jeffrey Feng: Okay, moving on to our next agenda Item. Have you guys decide what documents we should submit for the next week?
Yooni Choi: Yeah, let me take a quick look at canvas.
Yooni Choi: Okay, we have a plan and design document you next week. Most of the stuff seems to overlap a lot with our previous documents.
Jeffrey Feng: Yes, for the planned document. We have introduction, different tasks, milestone plans, terminology and incronom explanations, references, and reflection
DAZHI PENG: for the design of me. We are introduction to the encountering systems architecture Did a design implementation overview design models can design deployment and tools and dependencies.
Yooni Choi: Okay, it doesn't seem too complicated. After finishing the documents we should submit them. I have 3 interviews next week, so I probably won't have enough time to double check the document system at them.
Jeffrey Feng: I am pretty flexible in the next week. So i'm fine with either way submitting the documents on great scope should be pretty straightforward.
DAZHI PENG: Yeah, I would also want to focus on Ec. Projects next week. That's another way. Any could without here. So i'll probably say another time in or next week.
DAZHI PENG: so I probably would also not be able to submit them.
Yooni Choi: Okay, Jeffrey, do you want to work on that? You can always let us know if you need any hope?
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, sure, I can do that i'll let you guys know when I finish the submission.
DAZHI PENG: Thank you very much for your help. Do you guys have anything you want to discuss in this meeting.
Yooni Choi: I think we are good. Everyone seems to have a clear idea what they're supposed to do next.
Jeffrey Feng: Okay, bye, bye.